hey guys i'm joey king and i play l
evans in the kissing booth
my name is joel courtney and i play lee
flynn in the kissing booth and today
we're gonna be taking the how well do
you know your bff
test on buzzfeed
check off each of the details you're
absolutely sure you know about your best
friend
i know joel's birthday it's january 31st
yes it is
i remember you're so well because we
celebrated your 21st together
on the set of the kissing booth so if
you don't remember mine i don't i'm not
like
i'm not gonna be but hurt your birthday
is
july 29th oh my god no so close though
july 30th
dang it i don't know your astrological
slime because i'm terrible with
astrology so i'm going to guess i don't
know
taurus nope aquarius actually i think
you're a pisces
no i'm a leo ah
really your middle name is
mitchell no what is it
dabney oh that's right i remember i made
fun of you for that
i was like that's crazy what the hell
how do you even spell that isn't that
crazy
joey lynn king
that is right the last thing you watched
on netflix
oh i'm gonna guess it was the floor is
lava no actually it's avatar the last
airbender
okay i've been seeing a lot of a lot of
memes were coming up about it because
i believe there might be doing a new
live action
so i got super excited about that and i
went back and binge watched like the
entire show
the last thing that you watched on
netflix would
have been did you watch the floors lava
no the last thing i watched was say i do
on netflix i
binged the entire series and i was
bawling the whole time
there's celebrity crush i know that joel
is gonna say his fiancee because he
doesn't have a celebrity crush so that's
my
final answer is joel's fiance mia
scholnick that's absolutely true
your celebrity crush benedict
cumberbatch for the last
yes okay cool i thought so your favorite
movie
this one's hard for both of us because i
don't really have one favorite movie
that's my thing okay i'm gonna pick
something that you and i that i watched
for the first time
ever with you ferris bueller's day off
i'm just gonna how does that sound
yes i love that movie you
i want to say something like the help
no no i thought you were going to say
like step brothers or something
i should have said step brothers what
was i thinking i don't know or like
nacho libre or something ridiculous
their first acting gig super 8 life
commercial
look at that we both got it oh their
favorite
snack at crafty i think yours was banana
chips
yes absolutely banana chips for you i
would say
popcorn yeah for sure their favorite
swear word joel doesn't really swear
that much
unlike me i think his favorite swear
word is damn it
yeah it's it's yeah i would say so if
i'm really
like angry then like it would get a
little
spicier um but i don't know
i usually want to say [ __ ] yup
okay their favorite alcoholic drink i'm
gonna say
you like a jack daniel's milkshake wow
so joel and i have this amazing insight
because we shot the whole movie in south
africa
in cape town and our favorite burger
spot was called royal eatery and we
would get burgers and milkshakes every
time their milkshakes are amazing
and uh joel would get a jack daniel's
oreo milkshake jack daniels peanut
butter
vanilla milkshake blew my
mind you're like a whiskey guy you like
whiskey yeah
really nice scotch whiskies so i would
give you a check mark on that one i'd
say
okay so for you little do you know this
is just filled to the brim with vodka
right now
so we had a really good time you really
enjoyed the gin bar
in south africa but i don't think gin
was your favorite
if you would say that i would give it to
you because i love gin and i love wine
wine was my actual answer either or you
get it because i love jin jin's great
okay their first kiss i knew your first
kiss
okay you go first you were 14 years old
and the other guy was much older
he didn't know that it was your first
kiss because you didn't want him to but
then it leaked somehow
and and he found out but he was very
kind and sweet and like very nice about
it
yes you got it your first kiss was in
a screen test for a job you were doing
you never kissed anyone before
and within 30 minutes of each other you
had to kiss three
different people and those were all your
first kisses
to see if you guys had chemistry or nuts
you kissed three random people for your
first kisses all at one time
yes that is accurate what a day okay
their favorite class in school
was like literature i didn't like
literature but it was not my
favorite what was your favorite history
oh
okay cool for you i would say
writing a literature writing no i love
to write but i'm a terrible writer i
loved history and reading
the first time we met it's hard to put a
pin on it
the first time we like really were like
okay we are
meeting now was the first day of ddr
rehearsal for the first movie and i
remember you pulled up and you had on a
minion shirt and i was like that's an
amazing shirt
we're gonna be friends we did meet that
day but i actually disagree
there was an event that you zack
annalise and i
went to and we played cards oh
oh my god three hours we were the only
four people
under the age of like 17.
wow oh my god you you get that one
okay cool their hidden talent
perfect you are one of the best burpers
i have ever met that is true i will take
that crown
happily well you had to learn how to do
this and you're really good at it now
you're really good at juggling oh i
would add
absolutely give you that check mark i
love juggling
i started learning in high school yeah
but for later on i did
i started learning how to do four and
it's tough favorite book okay i don't
know your favorite book at all so i'm
just gonna guess
i'm gonna say the alchemist no i really
like
pilgrim progress i think there's like
it's such a fun
allegorical way about it your favorite
book
oh i have no idea my
favorite book is called a little life
it's the most heartbreaking
beautiful book i've ever read their
biggest pet peeve i don't know yours you
don't know mine
bad hygiene no no my
biggest pet peeve is a word i can't even
say it s-t-i-n-k-y
oh my god don't say it's the gross word
i've ever heard in my whole life
i forgot about that your biggest pet
peeve is
unprofessionalism no bad drivers
pre-filming
ritual i think yours is just to like
make people laugh
i'll give you that i think yours is the
same
actually yeah i'd give you that too and
just loosen up a little bit favorite
band or singer
you like coldplay don't you well i mean
yeah but not like
my favorite by any means if i was gonna
like pick someone to listen to
right now i would pick john mayer oh i
did know that
no i did know that one i knew that one
for you i would say
j cole no yes i love
j cole but that wouldn't be my favorite
i mean he'd be one of the favorites sure
you can take that
favorite dance move you like the bernie
i do like the bernie
i'll totally give you that one uh that's
my that's one of my go-to moves
that's crazy actually i don't know your
favorite dance move you're just so loose
and
free and like always dancing everything
yeah take it i mean i just like to dance
their phone number without checking your
phone not
a chance and even if i did i wouldn't
say it
ain't either you got 12 out of 20.
wait you got 12 out of 20 as well we
tied
look at us you know we know each other
pretty well
i learned something new about you i
learned a few new things about you
but i'm i'm a little bit sad that we
only got to help
i know i'm pretty i'm pretty bummed that
we i only got 12 out of 20
but um i'm mad at myself about your
middle name i'm bummed about your
favorite
movie i feel like i should have known
that one no
that's okay i mean it's not my actual
favorite movie it's my silly favorite
you